smart no hesitation you were talking
about that corporate drives and finishes
it's time to stop talking about him as a
young player he's just a really good
place inside heaven love goes right back
aron baynes who checked in James picks
up his dribble shot clock winding down
James falling away three LeBron James 19
points already
now that's his fourth three-pointer this
is good defense this is a very good job
Marcus smart but LeBron James just
feeling himself right now and he's a guy
that when he said he wasn't worried you
believe roles or individually off the
dribble
my role gets its I know it's blocked by
Green knocked out of bounds last touched
by the Cavs Jeff Green whoa
[Music]
Luongo rebound tip lights Thompson
knocked away by Brown here comes rose
here throws it down
this building has exploded heroes here
off the steel understands LeBron James
he's looking to chase him down says not
on my watch
take that I call that Terry law Jeff
Green thrown away picked up by brown
vines Rosia proof behind that lamp
blocked by James Horner sensational
block still now 9 and Owen the playoffs
here on the parquet floor a brilliant
second half from the Boston Celtics
[Applause]